[Music]
imagine if you could build a tunnel that
sliced through the center of the earth
suddenly you could travel to opposite
ends of our planet with ease simply hop
into the tunnel and let gravity whisk
you towards your destination
initially gravity's pole would
accelerate you down toward the Earth's
center but as you pass through the core
gravity would start to work against you
here's how long it would take you to
reach the other side first you must
create a vacuum by removing all air out
of the tunnel otherwise friction in the
form of air resistance will slow you
down to much an air pressure near the
center would crush you to death next
you'll need to wear a spacesuit which
will protect you against the intense
heat at the core and supply you oxygen
to breathe after removing the air and
suiting up you could freefall through
the vacuum tunnel assuming the force of
gravity is constant throughout your trip
it would take about 19 minutes for you
to reach Earth's center you would be
blazing along at 25,000 miles per hour
or 32 times the speed of sound but you
would feel completely weightless just
like an astronaut in space is passed
through the core your speed would slow
down but your momentum would continue to
propel you upward against gravity by the
time you reach the other end you would
be back to a walking pace total the trip
would take about 38 minutes
that certainly beats a 40 hour plane
ride from Santiago Chile to Xian China